joining us now on the phone as he's uh
he's smarter than mooch he's not coming
to the stadium for work yet mooch was
suited and booted completely oh it's
ready to go
I mean honestly he looked like he was
about to use a banker like he was about
to do his banking for me the way he
looked he is though for the seventh year
in a row part of our first round
coverage live on the NFL Draft love
having him he is Stanford football coach
David Shaw how are you coach hey Rick
how you doing I'm doing fine appreciate
you appreciate you joining alright let's
get right into it do you do you think
Baker Mayfield is worthy of the number
one overall pick coach
you know that's such a tough call
because we talked about this the other
day you know I passed my brain just
watching the film as this kid this is so
exciting the other half of my brain says
there has not been a successful
first-round draft pick under 62 in a
long long time so that this will be a
tough call for me I agree with mike
Mayock Sam Thomas the smart pick him
Donald estate pick it has less potential
for the bottom falling out and if you're
the Cleveland Browns I don't think you
can roll the dice again so you're a guy
who has seen darn 'old and rosin up
close which one do you think is most Pro
ready coach I think they're both Pro
ready and I think they're different I
think Sam Donald has the edge just
because of his mobility that lettuce
isn't in place will hurt you with its
leg but when you watch just watch a guy
throw the football
Josh Rosen close to balls anybody to
come out of luck so when it's all said
and done how do you see the draft going
tonight
oh based on what you think should be
done you know the common sense approach
which you and I both know always what
teams do when they have the infinity
would love to see fans Arnold go number
one
I think it'd be great for to kind of
stabilize that franchise all the facts
have gone through there I think this
young man is athletic he's smart he's a
gym rat he's gonna be all the way there
with them
I think the Giants is number two and so
many people calling for a quarterback
which I understand but state quantum
Berkeley you team that up with the Titan
they took last year
the receiving cords they have a
quarterback that they have it
immediately puts them I think right back
up this top of the NFC and then after
that bit of a crapshoot I personally
would love to see Josh Rosen but I know
a lot of people talking Baker make field
at the chest but they have to take a
quarterback and both of the guys do make
sense for the den David Shaw Stanford
Cardinal head football coach joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show the day of
the NFL Draft were finally gonna get
some answers to all this he's joining me
right here on the Rich Eisen show so
Josh Allen and the tweets that came out
today you as a coach that's been around
Millennials been around kids been around
social media and also been in draft
rooms yourself in your stints in the
National Football League what do you
think the evaluation of Josh Allen is
right now as you and I are talking with
the the clock about the start in a few
hours yeah there are a lot of a lot of
conversations because if you talk about
red flags the difference when something
that's a red flag and something that's a
true concern about a young man's
character and who he is all the
questions really have been answered by
everybody at Wyoming and all the dirt
digging that everybody does before this
day ever comes sometimes things come
back from high school and as so many
people know in high school these young
men don't understand that these things
stay there for a long time we did the
session with our guys we had a group
come in and go all the way back since
they started their social media accounts
and go back and look and see if these
these things actually represents you
because a lot of these guys do things
without thinking they think they're just
talking to their friends without putting
things out there into the atmosphere
which is really what happens now so I
don't know that it's a huge concern but
I know a lot of people raised eyebrows
in the last 24 hours
well how do you think Alan's going to be
received when he walks into a locker
room by whichever team address him you
know this is a big man's game you know
all you do is pump your chest out walk
out there say hey you know if that was
me being being a young kid that's not
who I am and when he walks in locker
rooms ok judge me now from here on out
and I think he's going to be able to do
that based on his track record
everything that's been said about him
during his entire time the Wyoming so
based on
on what you know about going through
social media accounts and and and due
diligence etc do you think that NFL
teams knew about this report potentially
before came out last night that
everybody's already who has any clue
about the due diligence process and
wanting somebody that they would have
done this like say the bills would have
done this on Allen if they this is the
cut that the quarterback that they
covered to trade up fourth there's a
very very good chance because it takes
very minimal effort most teams use
different investigative services that
are not very expensive and not very
difficult this is not a very difficult
thing to go back and find so a lot of
teams I know they do that on every
single draftable person to go all the
way back so I'm sure a lot of people
know about it probably didn't come up
with some people say you know what that
was high school to do and say it's dumb
things in high school before they're
even you know seventeen years old so
some people knew about it and didn't
think it's a big deal a few more minutes
left with coach David Shaw Stanford
Cardinal head football coach part of the
NFL network's coverage tonight that will
be simulcast on Fox of the draft rooms
that you have been in in your time and
professional football the Baltimore
Ravens is certainly one that you have
some experience knowing the DNA and
obviously Ozzie Newsome making his final
first-round draft selection of his
general managing career do you see Lamar
Jackson as a fit and something that the
Baltimore Ravens would be willing to
endeavor knowing what that room is all
about I do I do you have an established
quarterback obviously and so this is
young man can come in you can try to
groom and get a chance to grow the Greg
Roman is there and Greg Roman has a lot
of success in San Francisco 49ers with
certain Colin Kaepernick so don't be
surprised there with the things that
they can do formational e and selection
wise to have it if he's not a starter
initiative maybe have a package that
goes in not just to run the ball but
just to do have a little factor to get
this guy's feet wet but I can see a lot
of to play well it's been 13 years since
you were last in that draft room is that
something you think that needs to be run
by Steve bisciotti before they go and
pull the trigger
I think people thought his in the room
but you're also talking about one of the
top general managers in the history the
NFL and I'm from his track record is
unbelievable the the guys that he picked
they're looking for certain
characteristics in his very very open
and very honest and very direct with all
the guys and draft from coaches Scouts
and even Steve bisciotti a clear vision
that he has for building a football team
so everybody that's on the top of his
list has been discussed and and run over
and today now as I say today's just his
game datum to make those calls so
tonight if the Colts are on the clock
and they don't trade out of that pick
and they have a choice between the top
defensive player or Quintin Nelson what
do you say to that
coach David Shaw Andrew Luck former head
coach and now very good friend I would
say take the garden Nelson you know the
front of that pocket is so important
this guy's one of the best quarterbacks
in NFL he's proven that without a lot of
help around them if we can secure the
front you know so that he can push up in
the pocket and do the unbelievable
things he's capable of doing now that
he's getting back healthy and ready to
go out there you'd love to take the
guard and and really secure searches to
secure that front around the franchise
all right and know your guys who your
guys that we're going to expecting to
hear about over this next few days coach
well here are some so horrible Harry's
they call the defensive tackle hundred
tackles this year its defensive lineman
which is just such a rare thing very
productive big physical guy and Justin
Reed these two guys may fall somewhere
in that late first round area just in
speed and athleticism the Flex position
flexibility those two guys have a chance
to impact teams right away all right
enjoy I guess when you make when you
kind of get in the car to come out here
when you're gonna come join the party
here a little bit close for the gametime
mood to be in the early bird you know
I'm fine with that guy work that you're
on the late bus today is what you're
saying are you a late bus guy oh
absolutely absolutely otherwise
we'll see you over here later on coach
thanks for the call well chat soon all
right dick you're rich yeah you got us
David Shaw the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience